i get a text from my manager and he was
like yo you booked it
it was such a defining moment because
you go from
acting and auditioning temporarily on
different shows and like coming in as
like
the visitor to like stepping in and
having your own show
hey gq i'm noah centeno and these are
some of my biggest moments
[Music]
i actually didn't realize that to all
the boys was gonna be a big deal
until it came out it wasn't until i like
woke up one morning
and my manager texted me and was like yo
check your instagram and i started to
see like
millions of people uh following me that
i went oh wow i guess
i guess it did well changed the way that
i go out of public it changed the way
that i get to meet people it's been
incredible
hey coffee
huh anything for your friend he's not
with me
i'd like a chocolate shake sure yeah the
scene that stands out to me
from the first film um is the is when
peter kavinsky meets
lara jean at the diner for the first
time because that was the first scene
that we actually ever shot
for the entire franchise ever together
me and lana everything that was decided
from that day forward
that's how i played the character for
the next three years
the korean grocery store is all the way
across town i know
so if i went all the way across town to
get you something that you like then
that means
you must really like yogurt
you i was in the hot tub for like 12
hours that day
they were like you can get out if you
want i went no i think i'd like to stay
here actually
and it was crazy because it looks like
we're outside at night
we're actually under this crazy tent
that production had built
so it was the middle of the day and like
everything was blacked out because the
tent that surrounded
and then lana and i like made out and it
was
great it was what it was and i guess a
lot of people liked it
[Music]
shannon and i got very close while
filming sarah burgess
she's such a like a pensive and like
careful
and like loving nurturing person we
spent as you can imagine a lot of time
together
and just got to connect and i think
that's one of my favorite things about
acting
in general is just you meet people and
you get to connect with them it was
really special
really special and ian samuels the
director created such a
a world you know we were using lenses
that were from like the 70s and 80s and
he really did a beautiful job of just
really making that world for us to kind
of step into
this is my brother ty and he's
deaf two what are the odds up there
it's crazy i'm gonna make him uh the
first
four-foot quarterback
i didn't learn fluent sign language
definitely not
but um i'd never acted with someone who
was deaf before
and so being able to experience that and
to interact with
my younger brother it was like a very
warm moment an endearing moment but then
it was also like
super fun for shannon and i because we
definitely had no idea what we were
doing
and you are
your name is [ __ ] pizza it was so much
fun filming
that scene
[Music]
it was the coolest thing because ross
butler and i had actually we've been
friends since before
we shot that film and so being able to
actually work with someone that i was
close with
on a personal level and just added a
whole another layer
and then jordan fisher and i actually we
knew each other i've known him since i
was 15.
we've been like walking into audition
rooms and call back rooms and seeing
each other
just special man all the different
people that came together on two
and three reuniting with lana it was
like going back to summer camp you know
we had such a kick-ass time doing the
first one
we got to see each other for the second
one but what was wild was like we had
both gone through a transition
because before no one really knew who we
were
afterwards more people knew who we were
after a year being able to kind of
reconnect and and process that
experience with each other was i think
very helpful
and healthy and then it was also amazing
to be able to work with her again
you can't think about us breaking up on
our first date
i just don't want us to break each
other's hearts
i promise i am not going to break your
heart the lantern scene
sets up the whole promise that is the
through line of the second movement it's
like i promise i'm not gonna break your
heart
which is like why would you promise that
to someone you can't promise that to
someone in fact sometimes love is
in breaking each other's hearts and
learning how to like mend that
then that's when a bond really
solidifies at times not always and it's
a beautiful moment too we were
in this huge park in vancouver and like
we really did set all of these lanterns
into the sky and one person's kind of
burned down it was
it was funny it was like ah i don't know
if i can say that
whatever and then uh at the restaurant
when i take lana to the the restaurant
after that
we did a full one shot we did a whole
like shot for shot of goodfellas didn't
make it
didn't make it to the movie wish it did
i don't really know
a lot about it there's definitely a
little bit of like um
magic right you have to add a little bit
of flair what we did was when we were
walking
away from the tree house we at some
point
step onto this platform and then there
were people hiding away in the corners
of the platform
and as soon as we step on and face each
other they like
hook us with these safety lines and then
the platform
goes up and the camera and everyone's on
it and we just all raised like 20 feet
into the sky
we rehearsed it like like six or seven
times the day before for like an hour
talked through it got on set did it i
love stuff like that like i want to do
more stunts i think stunts are super fun
lana was so great she was like the first
few times she was all nervous
[Music]
i had only recurred on one show before
then
i went to the call back then they told
me that they wanted me to test for it i
i don't think i'd i had never tested for
anything before i go in
i do my thing they asked me to leave so
i leave i had one of those uh
those little scooters that you stand on
not the segways but one of those like
hawkeye it was like
right when those started coming out i
had my backpack and i started from
burbank i went all the way to
camarillo north hollywood by the jersey
mics
and it died right around there and i was
like ah what am i gonna do
and i looked at my phone and my phone
was dead too and i was like
and but i remember my homie lived right
around the corner
so i just showed up to his place he
wasn't there so i sat out
at his house and i waited like 30
minutes then he just showed up i was
like what's up man
so i go in i plug my phone in i plug in
my weird scooter thing
i get a text from my manager and he was
like
yo you booked it it was such a defining
moment because you go from
acting and auditioning temporarily on
different shows and like coming in as
like
the visitor to like stepping in and
having your own show
where you're a foundational element of
the entire project
it created a lot of stability for me it
created so much confidence for me the
foster is like
i'd consider that my collegiate
education when it comes to acting
peter page bradley bretowig joanna
johnson
you know all the writers the cast it was
a family
the executive team had such a vision and
had such a
a purpose for the show it really
permeates to the people that watch it to
the fans
it's one thing when people come up to me
and say oh my god i love jewish peter
kavinsky oh my god i loved you as jaime
but it's different when someone comes up
to me and says i'm a huge fan of the
fosters
it changed my life i just had to say hi
those people
almost immediately like i would sit down
and just like have
coffee with them because i understand
the impact that that show has had
could be more grateful to have been
selected
[Music]
i just got a call one day and said hey
you're the choice for this music video
you want to do it i said
absolutely are you kidding me it had
like a pool of people that they were
looking at and i was the one that
got lucky enough to be chosen and very
fun i i had done a music video but i've
never done like a music video
very cute camila's incredible what a
vibrant loving
like energetic positive
like person it was very like quick like
i think they had
locked a lot of the choreo beforehand
when i got there
we would work with the choreographers
and figure it out really quick
good good okay great awesome great we're
gonna go do this scene and we'll come
back and then
we'll do this one i was like all right
cool my favorite moment of the video is
when we're outside
and i picked me up put her on the car
and she like
slaps me and i've ever just been like yo
just slap me like just just go for it
and she did and it works you know it was
like it was so funny because
i don't want to hurt you it's like no no
go for it but she she can hit
it it was a solid hit very fun very fun
i keep saying that but it was you know
[Music]
that was the first studio film i've ever
worked on in my entire life the the size
of the production
is just like it's huge the
professionalism
between the crew the cast eb everyone
involved
and then also the willingness to have
fun with each other
on and off set to really play with each
other and give each other
in a scene so much i'd experienced it
with with other films but to see it
done in such a masterful way was quite a
learning experience for me
did you did you do that
oh yeah i think he uh finally
got the point is that a pun because you
impaled him
i had to keep up i had to try to keep up
as best that i could
and then ella ella belinska like we had
so much fun together man
she's super fresh with acting as well
and like so
she does her own stunts ella belinska
does her own stunts all of them
everything like she's in the car she
jumps out of the car she's shooting the
gun it jams it wasn't supposed to jam
she fixes it continues going like it
looks sick she taught me if anything
that like
yo do your own stunts learn how to do
your own stunts
so i'm trying but i will never be as
good as ella belinska is
[Music]
langston oh my god
he's been in there all the time you hit
a person in my louis xiv
meeting patrick that was crazy i was in
there for
i can't tell you maybe 30 takes just
chilling
tied up and then like they open and i
just fall out
it was very fun it was very very fun
that whole scene was hilarious and
and i think patrick just the way that he
like
commands that moment and kind of throws
me away as a character
he's like oh it's like really [ __ ] up
what's happening but you know
he killed it um obviously he killed it
[Music]
your team's like hey man listen this is
a film that's coming out like
we're we're taught we're in talks for it
we don't know what's gonna happen blah
blah blah
and you're like all right cool like that
would be insane working with
dwayne johnson and jama and but i always
try to manage my expectations and
be like yeah no like i would love to but
like the odds of it happening are zero
like
and then you get this follow-up call and
it's like
no you got it i mean it's just an
example of how my life has changed
i grew up acting when i was eight
auditioning
driving like an hour to auditions every
single weekend then when i came out to
la when i was 15 i was auditioning
daily throughout the week you know just
driving to auditions all the time all
the time and like
hoping to get a call back and then you
get a call back and then
you never book you know you do that for
years it's challenging work and it's
good work and you have to be dedicated
and consistent
just to get like that one liner suddenly
you get offers for studio
superhero films with dwayne johnson you
know it's like
ridiculous
[Music]
favored nations technically we started
working on it two years ago
it was an idea that started in my head
as like a philanthropic
apparel company and then it's grown into
something much larger and much more
multifaceted than just that the genesis
of it was i was 17 years
old and like i've always wanted to
design
hoodies or t-shirts or items and then
sell them and have the money that was
raised from that go to charity to
support a cause i promised myself that
if i ever was successful and got a
platform from acting
then i would use that to not just fuel
my own interests but like to help other
people
i'd been acting on self-interest
only for years and i was not happy like
i
was actually like very anxious and i had
crazy mood swings and i didn't know why
i didn't feel fulfilled and it was just
because i was acting selfishly and so
when told the boys blew i was like yo
this is it this is my opportunity to
actually do something that i want to
actually do something to help people
it's a philanthropic lifestyle brand
instead of us raising a bunch of money
and giving it to
a non-profit that would use that money
for overhead
we're going to find smaller more
targeted and direct nonprofits
that will actually take that money and
put it towards use
and good use for the cause that you care
about there's a lot of different parts
to it but
that's why i created favorite nations
so artie's a friend of mine his manager
kyle mccarthy is one of my best friends
on this planet
and we've all known each other for years
when they did save me tonight
they were like we were talking about it
and i was like yeah man i would love to
direct one of your songs i don't know
that's a thing
he goes that's crazy i was literally
gonna ask you if you wanted to direct
this one it was a surreal experience i'd
never directed before
but being able to jump into it with such
talented people and
that kind of helped lead it and and walk
me through the process from start to
finish
and to do it with someone i'm so close
with like artie
um made it just super relaxing was it
anywhere near as stressful as you would
think it would be
i mean working with lily she she is so
good
so talented and just so present and so
there with you it was a simple music
video shoot
with friends and she just like poured
her heart into it
i love her she's so great the theme of
it is
you know friendship finding good people
that can help you overcome challenges
because that's really what artie
and i's relationship is built off of is
just a friendship and so
we wanted that to play out uh in the
video as well and we wanted a lot of
color
so we did the color explosion
which was fire so crazy when you're
there in person